this was not accident he did not trip
and fall and find himself upon george
floyd's knee and neck he did
what he did on purpose
the state has failed to prove its case
beyond a reasonable doubt
the prosecution and defense laid out
their closing arguments today in the
derrick chauvin trial good afternoon
thank you so much for joining us at four
i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
casadas let's head right out to michael
george in minneapolis where many are
anxiously awaiting the verdict
[Music]
on top of him for nine minutes and 29
seconds
the prosecution implored the jury to
find derrick chauvin guilty
use your common sense use your common
sense
believe your eyes what you saw you saw
in a lengthy closing argument the state
said the former minneapolis police
officer
chose pride over policing when he pinned
george floyd down
last may the kind of ego based pride
the defendant was not going to be told
what to do
i submit to you that the state has
failed
to meet its burden of proof beyond a
reasonable doubt
the defense argues floyd died of
underlying heart disease and drug use
and said chauvin's actions in context
were reasonable
the 9 minutes and 29 seconds ignores
the previous 16 minutes and 59 seconds
a reasonable police officer would in
fact
take into consideration the previous 16
minutes
and 59 seconds minneapolis is holding
its breath
three thousand national guard troops are
stationed throughout the city
and already tensions are inflamed after
the death of 20-year-old dante wright at
the hands of police in a nearby suburb
just last week outside the courthouse
the floyd family joined activists
in a prayer vigil so many people stepped
up in the city
standing up for drugs that enough for
what's right chauvin faces
charges of second degree unintentional
murder third degree murder and second
degree manslaughter
he took off his mask during closing
arguments for only the second time
during the trial
michael george cbs news minneapolis
well sheldon faces up to 40 years in
prison if convicted of the most
serious charge